Today, Europe as a political entity has a chance
it never had in its long and turbulent history.
The chance to organise itself
in a truly just and peaceful way
on the principle of equality and cooperation of all.
To reflect on Europeanism is to ask
what the ideals or principles are
that the notion of Europe evokes
or is characteristic of Europe.
I have the feeling that in my youth,
I would have felt a bit ridiculous
if I said or wrote that I was European,
that I felt and thought like a European.
And that's probably how it is for most Europeans.
They are quintessentially European,
but they don't realise it.
It was no accident that,
shortly after the communist dictatorship was established,
it began to violently destroy the fibres of civil society
and essentially eliminate it.
What was left of authentic civil society lived
and evolved as direct or indirect resistance.
The task of helping new democracies in this respect
should be a natural part of our larger task:
continuously deepening and strengthening
civil society on a pan-European scale.
Respect for human life and human freedom
as well as consideration for pan-European security
may require intervention beyond the borders
of the European Union as a last resort.
Both in Kosovo and Serbia
and in Bosnia and Herzegovina,
in other parts of the former Yugoslavia too,
tens of thousands of human lives and immeasurable material value
could have been spared
had the international community been able to intervene earlier
in an appropriate manner at the beginning of the conflicts.
Evil must be nipped in the bud
and it is not enough if it is confronted only by governments.
The attitude of governments must grow out of citizens' attitudes.
We all know that the enlargement of the European Union
is conceivable only when accompanied
with a continuous and no less courageous reform of its institutions.
I would be happy if the country from which I come
could participate as a full partner in all of this.
Thank you for your attention.